édouard ER is back with the mothership
our old buddy cowboys reporter for ESPN
also covering other Dallas related
sports and Edie
joining us now congratulations head well
thank you Dan I'm glad to be back and
appreciate being invited to have the
opportunity to speak with you on the
show didn't the Commissioner voice his
displeasure when ESPN lets you go a
couple years ago I don't know if he I
doubt he said anything publicly if he
said anything it was probably very
private and quiet but I think in the
league office there may have been some
concern just about the number of people
who you know covered the NFL for for
ESPN who focused primarily on the sport
itself and I just know that Roger
Goodell has been supportive of me in
terms of one of the first calls I got
after I was laid off was from an NFL
team that wanted to hire me and Roger
because I asked and he had previously
offered was involved in trying to help
me negotiate that situation which
ultimately didn't work out but he has
been supportive of me and I'm
appreciative and I know he doesn't
expect that that's gonna color my
objectivity going forward ed is joining
us from Cowboys training camp in Oxnard
California is the feel the same every
day when you're there you mean in terms
of my role covering the team no just
drama yeah because it's everything a
sort of status quo with Zeke and dak
Mari Cooper you know Jerry Jones usually
talks everyday I think so is it there's
this Groundhog Day for you because
there's no movement here and when do you
expect any movement on these contracts
well Jerry Jerry really doesn't talk
everyday he's he's spoken once in the
three days since I've been here he
generally talks before and after every
Cowboys game it's it's one of the unique
experiences that there there is in the
NFL Dan is that you know during the
regular season after every game Jerry
Jones goes in the locker room and either
listens to
you know Jason Garrett addressed the
team or he participates in that process
and then he comes out and literally the
media has to walk right past one of the
most flamboyant owners in the NFL a guy
who is fully in charge of his team and
has very strong public opinions he's
willing to share in order to go in the
locker room and I talked to the players
who just performed in the game or to go
down the hall and listen to the to the
head coach who you know managed the game
so yeah when Jerry Jones talks it would
be a mistake not to be within earshot or
having the opportunity to ask him
questions but I don't know that there's
as much drama as people probably
perceived there to be just based on how
much talk there is publicly in the media
about these three players Ezekiel
Elliott dak Prescott and Amari Cooper
you know Travis Frederick I thought put
it well yesterday the center well he
said you know what there's a lot of
public discussion about these three
players and their contracts but if you
stick your head in any of our meeting
rooms
you won't hear anything at all about
anything except you know playing the
game of football and what our routine is
going to be day to day who blinks first
in these contract talks either Zeke side
Dax side even Amari Cooper's son well
the way I've been told to expect the
contracts to be executed even though the
Cowboys insist they haven't prioritized
one over the other and Steven Jones said
you know hey you know we were capable of
multitasking and we can do more than one
contract at a time he said in fact we
have offers to all three and if they all
got hot we could conceivably sign them
all in one day although I don't expect
that to happen but he said what happens
is you know we we send an offer they
don't like it so they huff and puff
about it then they send us a counter and
we're upset about it so we don't respond
for you know a couple of weeks and
that's kind of how the way it plays out
now I think that despite what Jerry
Jones has said about you don't need a
rushing champion to you know win an NFL
title and you don't and and boy Tony
Pilar this fourth round pick
that we got is really impressed and
could carry the load to say that after
you know four carries in the first
preseason game and so and suggests that
he could replace a two-time NFL rushing
champion who led the NFL and carries
since he came into the league is is
somewhat preposterous and obviously just
posturing I think Jerry recognizes he
has to get a deal done with Ezekiel
Elliott before week one and I but I
don't think the time to stress about it
is quite arrived yet I think that will
probably happen after the final
preseason game I mean if you just look
at it then you know when I've been here
and talking to Stephen Jones and talking
to Jerry you get the very strong sense
that they feel this is the the deepest
and most talented roster that they've
had since they won three Super Bowls in
the 1990s but they think when they make
their there cuts it's going to be the
hardest thing they've had to do in
thirty years from a roster standpoint
and you know Jerry Jones is 76 years old
and Jason Garrett a coach you know he
has supported long beyond the time most
would a guy he really wants to win and
staked his reputation on has been forced
into the final year of his contract and
he's doing this with a first-time you
know play caller in Kellen Moore who's
the new offensive coordinator do they
really want to start the season without
the player they built the whole thing
around I just can't see them taking that
risk who leaked the dak Prescott numbers
I have no idea but you would have to
believe since it harmed dak Prescott to
suggest that he was seeking forty
million dollars that it came from the
team side you know I think it's a it's a
tough negotiation and you know Jerry did
admit the other day and this is to his
leverage obviously but you know hey we
you know Dec if he wants to you know
play on the last year of his contract an
honor that then we're fine with that if
you must have make two million dollars
instead of you know whatever seventy
million guaranteed we'd be ok with that
but he also mentioned for the first time
the the risk to each of these players
you know the risk of injury to dak
Prescott who who is plant has never
missed a game
he's the only
quarterback in franchise history to
start you know the first three seasons
of his career and not miss a game but he
did suffer 56 acts last year the most in
the NFC and so Jerry mentioned hey
there's a risk there if he decides to
play out his contract he could also
perform poorly and compromise his
negotiating position going forward if
that were to be the occurrence
especially if he doesn't have his Eagle
Elliott
we saw how dependent damages on you know
the players around him when when they
didn't have a Mario Cooper for the first
half of the season not that every
quarterback in the NFL doesn't need
quality receiver and the cowboy is
front-office has acknowledged its
failure in that regard but yeah I think
I think I think it's possible that dak
will wind up not signing until after the
season begins and maybe he'll play out
the whole year although I think it's an
incredibly risky decision I've been
saying that more NFL players should
adopt the NBA players philosophy if I'm
dak Prescott I bet on myself I got an
unbelievable offensive line you know
Zeke will be in camp eventually and Mari
Cooper is going to be re-signed how
about a two-year deal where you say to
the Cowboys look I'm gonna give you a
discount I'm gonna sign two years I want
sixty three million dollars guaranteed
two years the new TV deal comes in in
2020 you go back into the hopper there
into the marketplace but you bet on
yourself we see this with you know Kawhi
Leonard is going to go hey I'll do two
years in an option or Kevin Durant is
doing this why wouldn't you do that if
you're dak Prescott well I mean he might
be willing to do that but I can't
conceive of any circumstance under which
the Cowboys would agree to such a thing
because the salary cap implications
would be beyond their control yeah and
the one thing that you know Jerry Jones
has stated is that he's not worried
about meeting the market that's been
created for these players based on their
position and the contracts most recently
signed at those positions he says his
job is to manage the salary cap in such
a way that they keep all three of these
players plus you know other young
players I talked about how talented they
think the roster is I mean they have you
know
players like Jaylon Smith I mean he was
a member of that 2016 draft class with
Zeke and and Prescott and he's been
dramatically underpaid based on the fact
that if he hadn't suffered that injury
to been a top five pick and instead he
falls you know to 34 in the second round
so he deserves a new contract Willie
Collins is a player who's going to
deserve another contract as a member of
that same draft classes so Gerry's
challenges you know to keep this nucleus
together going forward and to do that
he's got to be careful about you know
his expenditure on the three players
that we've spent a lot of time talking
about and it was interesting to me Dan
the other day said hey you know what we
could get a deal done with somebody
other than one of these three players
before we do a deal with any of the
three and I think the player could be
Jaylon Smith it was a phenomenal
linebacker and become the leader of
their defense and as a player who
overcame a devastating knee injury in
his final college game that a lot of
people quite honestly mocked the Cowboys
for drafting him in the second round but
that's one of the big risks that Jerry
took that that has paid huge dividends
has it always worked out that way but it
hasn't the case of Jaylon Smith where's
Zeke Elliott he's still in Cabo or
whoever you know what I don't know where
he is he was in Cabo but I don't know
his whereabouts I just know he's not
with his team and if anywhere else he is
as long as he's behaving properly and
not putting himself in any kind of
Jeopardy with off the field decisions I
don't I don't think it's a much concern
but you know and the Cowboys have said
hey you know we're confident he can hit
the ground running we know he's working
out handling it as a professional but
you know when he missed the six games
during a suspension and went to Cabo and
was kind of responsible for himself
remaining in football shape for when he
came back for what you know they
imagined would be a playoff run at that
point he was immediately effective he
had 97 yards in the game against Seattle
his first week back and then he had over
like 107 against Philly the next week
but the Cowboys felt like he came back
and he was not in in in shape that he
was you know 5 to 10 pounds too heavy
obviously they can't afford for that to
happen when they start the season if he
comes in late more trepidation just
dak Prescott long-term or Zeke Elliott I
wouldn't worry at all about signing dak
Prescott as long as you're comfortable
with his skill set and you you believe
he can succeed with it in your offense
with whatever coaching staff you have as
I and I have no doubt the Cowboys feel
that way I mean Jon Jon Kitna talks
about this kid he says hey the first
time you know I he's a new quarterback
Satoshi says first time I talked to dak
Prescott he said to me I want to be the
best that's ever played and I want you
to to get that out of me I want you to
coach me hard I want you to tell me when
I'm right and when I'm wrong and you can
put that in writing so you know there's
no equivocation about within the
organization about Dax ability to
perform at the level necessary in their
mind to contend for championships going
forward you know physically he's got you
know very thick legs you know as like I
said played every game so there's not
really an injury concern with him he's
done nothing but show good judgment on
and off the field is he's highly
respected by his teammates I mean for
him Dan to come in that first year when
Tony Romo got her after being the
starter for ten years for dak to perform
so well and have such a great
relationship with the locker room and
the coaching staff that there was no
chance whatsoever for Tony Romo to ever
get his job back I think really speaks
to how this player is viewed by his
teammates and his coaching staff so I
guess I would have fewer qualms about
investing in him and given the length of
time quarterbacks typically play then I
would running back you know who whose
career is typically much shorter and
Ezekiel Elliott who's you know one bad
decision away from a long suspension at
the same time they they made the
decision when they drafted him fourth
overall that they need an elite running
back to operate their team the way they
want and that's not the way most teams
operate most teams values a quarterback
in the passing game over the running
that's not the way the Cowboys are
structured you know they've got three
highly paid offensive linemen among the
highest at their positions on the
offensive line they drafted Elliot
fourth overall made a big investment in
him and are about to make another one
I was instructive Dan week 17 last year
they're getting ready to go in the
playoffs a Giants game is meaningless
meaningless to them who did they sit
they sat as Ecole Elliot they played dak
Prescott had great stuff glad you're
back with the mothership of course
covering the Cowboys and other Dallas
related sports we appreciate your time
as always Dan thanks for the great
questions I appreciate it I talked to my
friend that's Edward ER Cowboys reporter
for ESPN for more Dan Patrick show tune
in the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]